two of the largest bank failures in
history happened this week but before we
talk about why I have a question why is
Jim Cramer so good at being so bad at
his job just months before they both
collapsed he said this these are never
ever talked about why because they're
too boring I like to make money boring
is good watch out for Signature Bank
that's my fave SBB Financial don't you
want this copy is a merchant bag with
deposit base the Wall Street have been
stankly concerned about this morning we
witnessed the second largest bang
failure in American history which
actually created a wave of fear
as the day went on hence the Dow
ultimately losing 345 points SMB 41.45
in the NASDAQ tell me 1.76 percent
and I have to admit he has a way with
sound effects now I understand why they
call it Mad Money
but there is one thing Jim Cramer isn't
wrong about which I know is shocking
fear is in the air and many are worrying
is my bank safe so today I thought we'd
break it all down the recent collapses
why the government has announced a
special bailout why some people are
happy with it and others are mad and of
course what's next let's start with the
facts
three major banks in the United States
have failed in a short period of time
silvergate signature bank and Silicon
Valley bank now silvergate was the
smallest with about 11 billion in assets
signature was like the mid-sized one and
Silicon Valley Bank was the largest now
silvergate and Signature Bank were well
known in the crypto space while Silicon
Valley Bank was massive in the tech
startup World however despite their
differences these banks failed for
similar reasons at a high level which is
this they all experienced a run on the
banks when too many people demand too
much money too fast and the banks don't
have cash on hand now I want to make
something clear it would be easy to draw
the comparison to the crypto crash in
2022 when several crypto companies like
FTX collapsed but there's an important
difference companies like FTX were
insolvent when there was a run on their
Banks they had no money to to give
whereas the banks were talking about
were illiquid meaning they had the money
but when they had the bank run some of
it was locked up in long-term assets
like bonds now to be clear these are not
the same things at all but things can
get a little fuzzy in the details for
example when a bank run happens what can
start as a liquidity problem can become
an insolvency problem if the bank has to
sell what they have for cash and let me
explain one of the safest Investments is
considered to be treasury bonds your
grandparents probably invest in it Banks
invest in them both for the same reason
they they provide a stable rate of
return so say your signature bank right
you've got billions of dollars in
customer assets where do you put it well
in the treasury Bots which let's say
earn you one percent a year you keep
some cash on hand for withdrawals but
you figure look if I need to sell these
I can sell my bonds right but what
happens if interest rates rise really
quickly well suddenly you have this
five-year Bond you bought a year ago
which gives you one person a year but
now the government is selling the same
five-year Bond and offering five percent
because of that now your bonds value on
the open market drops it's no longer
even worth what you paid for it because
it's giving less interest than other
bonds and so if you try to sell that
well now you lose money now to be clear
if you held the bond to maturity well
you would still make that one percent
and not lose anything but when
depositors are asking for cash it's
simply not an option to hold on now I
know that seems complicated but the
essence of it is this Banks were forced
to sell long-term assets that they
didn't want to sell like bonds and they
took losses because of these Bank runs
because of that what started as a
liquidity crisis became an insolvency
crisis and that's why they got shut down
because they weren't going to be able to
service all those withdrawals so now
what right doesn't the government
Guarantee Bank deposits why are we even
talking about this well
they kind of do the FDIC insures up to
250 000 per account however at places
like Silicon Valley Bank they had a lot
of accounts with a lot more than that
because as we spoke of they hosted a lot
of venture capital startups that might
have had anywhere from 10 to 50 million
dollars in there and suddenly that
company which was healthy yesterday now
can't get access to that money and can't
meet payroll because their bank had
failed and this triggered a huge
response from many in Silicon Valley to
call for depositors to have their money
guaranteed with people like Jason
calacanus saying you should be
absolutely terrified right now that is
the proper reaction to a bank run and
contagion guarantee all deposits up to
10 million or this will spiral into
chaos and comments like this sparked a
huge debate on whether the government
should or would get involved ultimately
with the answer coming on Sunday when
the U.S treasury said this quote
depositors will have access to all of
their money and there you have it the US
government is stepping in to save not
only Silicon Valley Bank but also
Signature Bank as well they did this
citing a systemic risk exception which
really boils down to a single idea uh
please don't panic guys please don't
please don't take out your money
ultimately the US government doesn't
want you worried about your bank
deposits however not everyone saw this
as a win many were quick to point out
that once again the government only
seems to step in to help a certain type
of person quote Mark Cuban bailout
Silicon Valley Bank tonight feds
approved Goldman Sachs needs 824 billion
approved JPMorgan Chase needs 416
billion approved Average Joe my wife has
cancer can we get Medicare we're broke
now I do have to tell you that those in
favor of the fed's actions will tell you
that this is an unfair characterization
that it's not the Super Rich getting
bailed out they'll point out that this
isn't a traditional bailout at all
because it only applies to the
depositors and that Executives and
shareholders will get nothing and that
sounds good except for the fact that
some Executives and shareholders in
Silicon Valley Bank had already cashed
out with Greg Becker the CEO selling 3.6
million dollars worth of his shares
right before their collapse and this
gets even worse when you consider that
Greg Becker was one of the people who
lobbied to deregulate his own bank
according to Heather Landy of course
quote the ability of these Banks to fly
under the radar in the US was no
accident Greg Becker svb CEO lobbied U.S
officials several years ago to raise the
asset Threshold at which banks would be
considered systemically important so
let's get this straight
they faced less regulatory scrutiny
because they weren't systemically
important according to them but when
everything goes wrong they're
systemically risky and must be bailed
out it's a classic case of wanting it
both ways now again this isn't the same
as the full bailouts we saw in 2008 and
regardless of whether you land on
whether there should have been or should
not have been a bailout the idea that
systemically risky Banks should get
special treatment and regular Banks I
guess don't sends a pretty clear signal
if you're rich you should move your
money into banks that are too big to
fail otherwise you run a systemic risk
of ending up on Jim Cramer feeling like
this